we are about to fight now i'm gonna go
cause we can go right now dog don't hold
me back dog don't hold me back all right
my god
[Music]
okay you know what jquery is no i don't
know what you need to think about
yourself sometimes before you start
insinuating yourself and other people
bidding well you know what denies i'm
gonna insinuate my stuff whenever and
wherever i please because it's a free
country [ __ ]
okay you know what oh we're doing this
okay so we're going to do here babe yeah
we are about to fight now bring it on
there
let's go i ain't even playing cause you
know what i'm stopping
i wish go ahead step to me up no i would
love for you to step to me i really
would
and that's all you're doing call me a
[ __ ] again
oh yeah call me a business okay no
your wish is great oh see what anybody i
would like to see what happens i would
love to see
what happens oh you do oh absolutely so
why don't you come and bring it then
[ __ ]
see no you are riding my last nerve and
i ain't even playing no more i am not
even playing no more oh it's all then
let's do something okay you want to go
do something [ __ ]
huh there we go let's do something uh-uh
eh
let's do something [ __ ] what
[Music]
we told you not to mess with us [ __ ]
y'all just saw that [ __ ] turn into two
little girls right
[Music]
i'm just gonna sit down and relax
hey watch where the [ __ ] you going oh my
gosh i'm so sorry oh
i didn't see you had a baby there man
i'm sorry i ain't trying to fight nobody
with a baby
yeah hell yeah you won't
lucky [ __ ] huh well you're lucky
i'm carrying this baby something like
that
look man you need to move on all right i
already told you i'm not gonna fight you
that's what i thought punk
wanna go cause we can go right now dog
what's going on right man what the hell
are you doing man what what what what
trying to i can bob and weave it what
you bitch-ass punk-ass [ __ ]
let's go come on man come on no don't
look at your boys look at me man don't
look at you boy
ow
oh okay you think you hard all right but
you know what i'm gonna show you what
time it is right now okay
slap me
right how about this huh not what you're
gonna do huh now it's gonna do you ready
because they can do it right now cause i
can take you out man you're looking
oh
oof
okay oh it's on now that's yup you did
you did
yes
this
what the
what now man
what now
let's go
you know what
it's not even worth it
that's what i man
so keep walking oh okay that's vomit
that is vomit
oh dear
[Music]
but babe
moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage huh
can i take your garbage yeah sure
you know
i find
the more garbage in the can
the better it feels to dump it all out
i suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here to fix the copier
yeah sure sure
hey how did you sometimes things
ain't really broken
it's the way we treat them
it needs to be fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is
who are you steve
well
if it isn't mr stanley
carl
you need to find your own troubled white
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
i was here first
[Music]
sweep this
[Music]
there can be only one
magical
lego
[Music]
good lord
are you all right
well
i guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again
oh you're a magical negro too
who you call a negro [ __ ]
[Music]
well
all right friends
the first fight of the evening will
feature one of my slaves versus one of
the slaves of my distinguished guest mr
jacob dixon
you know robert i hope you are as
gracious a loser as you are a
host
all right
enough talk
[Music]
now
fight you devils fight to the death
[Music]
hey hey um
question
how do we get out of this thing alive um
it's it's really simple just just let me
pretend to kill you
hmm
maybe it just makes more sense if i
pretend to kill you yeah
yeah
i just
i want to make it believable so
that's that's what i was going for too
what the blazes is going on over there
and that endless clench tear him apart
okay
just just die from this from this um
uh just you know what i just something
doesn't feel right so if i can just if i
just let me okay go with me or something
that was it that was it this feels much
more real so really what why um sorry
what do you mean why it's all right my
god
i'm getting frustrated now damn it kill
oh
stop fighting like sissies and kill each
other
all right let's just check this out all
right we'll back up
and uh you run at me real fast just do a
bunch of spins and kick some flourishes
and i'll just knock you out one punch
and then you're dead right no wait wait
what i'm sorry so you can look cool no
thank you if someone doesn't die soon i
will kill you both thank you
that's
[Applause]
okay we both slam into each other and we
both die
fair
that's fair
one
this will be good
two
three
oh you son of a [ __ ] you were never
gonna fall you didn't even try to fall
down you were never the biggest thing
that's your you know don't let that
don't no don't hit me oh what's this
come
on everybody
war's over
slavery is abolished
sorry
we'll call it a draw done good for you
though huh
thank you let's go
well wait before you no no no no no no
hold up let's just just if just if
i may who do you think would have won
the fight between the two of us
[Music]
i said i said it right there i was like
it's like i was like you a woman i'm a
man that's a different kid oh what
they bumping up in here here it is it's
going off yo
hey
when i speak
well
my friends holding me you lucky cause
i'll take your head off don't hold me
back dog don't hold me back oh okay and
don't worry
see
i know though
if i were to lunge at you right now my
friend right here he catch me at the
last possible second no no no i won't
but my friend does
have the cognizance
to tell me i don't need to be going up
and committing capital murder up in a
club tonight hold on just knock him
unconscious dog pam
[Music]
i'm gonna kill anybody
no need for that success
turn him up
[Music]
sir
i will
oh snap you know what you lucky my boy's
using his telekinetic powers to hold me
back right now no i'm not
well maybe
it's the type of telekinesis that's a
mutant power that you didn't realize you
had until the moment
it started
oh i got it i see i see it so you want
me to hold you
i'm a dragon
oh yeah i want to rip this i'm a lion
i'm a tiger over here i'm a bear oh my
oh i go crazy on you oh i can't believe
him in there he's like he's like a
tornado i mean don't hold me back i
can't even believe i can hold him back i
can't even do it man believe i'm this
strong let me go look at this i'm one
and i can't even believe i'm this strong
let me just look at this man i'm gonna
hold it for one finger he's like a
little baby he can't get past me he's
like a little owl what
what you i'm a little baby i'm holding
you back man stupid yeah i got carried
away i apologize which mean you got
carried away you told me hold your back
i was holding your back what you want me
to do in a fight situation new means no
and yes means yes how would i have known
that so what oh what come on man ow come
on that hurt
and you holding me back now thank you
very much for that okay we'll just at
least change it up
okay now you listen
[Music]
happy sunday esther happy sunday
georgina
how was your week oh the lord is with me
but the devil
he got his hands on my grandniece grace
oh no
they're smoking the reefer doing the
hanky-panky with boys
esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he doesn't let go of my grandma's
grace
i'm gonna cut the devil's dick off and
shove it in his ass
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will joe gina
i know you will
how was your weak girl oh you know me
i'm blessed and thankful for everything
all right but you know my grandson jason
got himself wrapped up in the leathery
claws of satan
not jason he got himself arrested for
the spray painting and the vandalism oh
lord and i tell you i never
raise my hand in anger but if he don't
let jason go i'm gonna punch that [ __ ]
satan in the nuts so hard and wipe the
dick licking smirk off his horned ass
face
with my prayers amen i know you will
after i know you will but esther i gotta
tell you something else now oh let it
out you know esther that i have found
serenity in the glory of heaven yes
but my daughter's husband bernard has
got himself wedged between the cleft
hooves and lucifer herself
she opened up her laptop computer
and found the pornography of women not
the pornography absolutely the
pornography of women not on a laptop
computer a laptop on youtube
i am a pacifist under god's request but
if he don't let go of bernard i'm gonna
sneak up on that [ __ ] ass lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time
and then i'm gonna sit on that
motherfucker's head and i'm gonna spread
my booty cheeks on that pig's face and
i'm gonna just pucker up my stink hole
and just tubes tubes tubs scoops
until that
[Music]
of course of course oh
georgina georgina georgina
oh i got nothing but face and god in
heaven above but i tell you my son's
wife crystal she got herself wrapped up
in the fiery wings of mephistopheles
she got caught using profanity with her
own children what at the dinner table oh
lord chad
oh i have nothing but love for every
creature on this planet but if he don't
let my darling crystal go i'm gonna
flirt with the devil oh oh show him a
little bit of shoulder how you doing he
gonna start looking away i'm gonna start
twerking start twerking he's gonna be
like whoa where he gonna be he's gonna
be drawn in seduce that little
[ __ ] you're gonna wanna leave
batting my eyelashes at him then when at
least inspects it and i got his trust
that's when i'm gonna ride that [ __ ]
i'm gonna give him the night of his life
and now he ain't never gonna forget i'm
gonna give him this way i'm gonna give
him that way and then right when he
about to climax that's when i'm gonna
clinch up my [ __ ] on that
motherfucker's red dick and i'm gonna
snack that [ __ ] [ __ ] off with a divine
kegel well you gotta snap that little
dick off
with your prayers of course with the
prayers yeah but that's right girl yeah
you go get him yes [ __ ] satan [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him indeed
[Music]
[Music]
satan
[Applause]
and this niggles your wreath
oh right now i got this dick in my hands
like an old rag
oh give me some of that
i want a piece of him
who is this crazy [ __ ] now
it's me [ __ ]
what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me oh yeah
i'm waiting
my personal lord and savior i swear
[Music]